[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute was mit
erdbeeren wir sind in ich heute abend
zum grillen eingeladen haben dass eltern
und habe ich gedacht dieser kuchen
beziehungsweise diese torte die kommt
immer gut an
nämlich eine erdbeertorte und immer wenn
man deshalb etwa standorte springer mit
bremer mit ist super lecker und jeder
mag dass wir machen jetzt alle erst
einen ganz schnellen wandel boden dann
machen wir die schmandt klimt und dann
auch schon das topping mit den erdbeeren
wir benötigen damals wasser zucker mehl
backpulver und vanille extrakt unser
boden ist wirklich ein witz rezepten
zuallererst die eier mit dem warmen
wasser und im zucker und geben das in
die rührschüssel unserer maschine ihr
könnt aber auch gerne euer handrührgerät
verwenden und das warme wasser hilft
jetzt einfach dass die eier sich besser
aufschlagen und es ist ratsam wenn die
eier nicht ganz frisch aus dem
kühlschrank kommt sondern schon
zimmertemperatur haben
[Musik]
für die eier masse wurde jetzt um die
fünf minuten lang auf höchster
geschwindigkeit geschlagen ist richtig
schön hält cremig und das ist jetzt auch
der wichtigste schritt gewesen und als
nächstes nehmen wir die trockenen
zutaten dazu also backpulver und mehl
das müsste jetzt bei diesem rezept nicht
7 einfach dazu geben und vielleicht ganz
kurz unterrühren
nur so lange bis sich das miteinander
verbunden hat das paar extra gebe ich
auch noch mit dazu
[Musik]
der teig ist fertig jetzt wollte ich
euch aber noch ganz kurz zeigen wie ich
meinen tortenring in backpapier
einschlage ein tortenring habe ich auf
26 cm eingestellt und das habe ich hier
ein backpapier zuschnitt es gibt das
ganz einfach mit ich drauf und dann
müsste ganz einfach nur das backpapier
immerzu einen seite klicken und den
tortenring dabei drehen
so das war es auch schon und jeder hat
so seine vorlieben obmann springform
oder mit buck kam bei mir ist es immer
je nachdem welches rezept ich verwende
und hier nehme jetzt den wagram weil ich
benutze den er gleich weiter zum
befüllen
die gebe ich jetzt ganz einfach auf ein
backblech und jetzt will ich den teig 1
[Musik]
und ihr werdet merken das ist relativ
wenig zeit weil wir wollen ja auch nur
ein boden und dafür reicht es vollkommen
der wird auch gleich nicht mehr
durchgeschnitten haben jetzt nur noch
etwas glatt gestrichen schön verteilt
und jetzt kommt in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für 14 minuten und danach
vollständig auskühlen lassen
[Musik]
der boden ist vollständig abgekühlt das
ist ganz wichtig für den nächsten
schritt und ihr könnt jetzt ganz einfach
mit einem tortenring meister hier
entlang fahren um den tortenring damit
fehlt erstmals bizkit boden entfernen
können wichtig ist nämlich das
backpapier untendrunter ab machen durfte
weitermachen und ich habe jetzt hier
auch schon eine tortenplatte und da gebe
ich das jetzt einfach umgedreht drauf
im nächsten schritt gebe ich den
tortenring jetzt wieder drum herum denn
wir müssen ja gleich die schmandt kam
rein füllen und ich mache mir noch gar
nicht sauber die spar mit dem schritt
jetzt einfach so einmal verschließen und
jetzt zeige ich euch die restlichen
zutaten die sie benötigen und dafür
kommt ja immer mit für die sahne
schmandt creme benötigen wir kalte
schlagsahne sahne fest außerdem
zwischenstand ja habe ich hier zucker 1
1 eine zitrone und etwas vanille extrakt
und für das topping benötigen wir
erdbeeren und für den guss etwas sauer
kirschsaft und adina für die leckere
salesch man kate ist eines ganz wichtig
nämlich dass die sahne eiskalt ist und
wisst ihr was ich sogar gemacht habe ich
habe meine schüssel und mein schneebesen
aufsatz in den kühlschrank gegeben für
eine halbe stunde dann kann auch
wirklich nichts schief gehen auch nicht
an seinem schönen sommertag wie heute
jetzt gebe ich die kalte schlagsahne
einfach rein fangen an sie auf höchster
stufe zu schlagen und gibt dann man
seine fans dazu uns vollständig steif zu
schlagen
[Musik]
die sache ist vollständig steif
geschlagen und ich mache ich erstmal die
maschine aus braucht jetzt nicht mehr
und kümmere mich jetzt um die restlichen
vier zutaten also spannend gelierzucker
sie habe ich noch den zitronensaft und
das vanille extrakt und das gibt es
jetzt ganz einfach in eine schüssel und
verrührt das mit dem schneebesen
[Musik]
so spannt masse rühren wir jetzt die
sonne unter und dafür nimmt jetzt ein
bisschen keinen schnee vision mehr
sondern einen teig schaber dann
funktioniert das ganze besser und das
ganze so in zwei schritten und dann ist
die creme auch schon fertig
[Musik]
und die sahne schmandt geben wir es ganz
einfach auf den boden und ihr müsst ihr
versprechen nicht jetzt schon naschen
ich habe letztens mal gemacht dadurch
den kuchen auch schon gebacken und ich
musste die ganze zeit naschen ich war
froh dass ein bisschen das übrig
geblieben waren die schüsse
das soll jetzt habe ich das hier noch
glatt gestrichen und jetzt bahn hat das
in den kühlschrank die küche ist ganz
wichtig denn jetzt ist die creme total
weise ihr könnt den bug trinkmilch
entfernt deshalb bitte mindestens vier
stunden kühlen oder wenn ihr möchtet
auch über nacht dann kann das quasi am
vortag schon zu bereiten und
wirkungsgleich man das gerne für kühl
ist und wenn jetzt die wartezeit
überstanden habt dann starten wir mit
dem guss und den mache ich jetzt ganz
einfach aus zwei zutaten die natürliche
grad schon genannt falls ich jetzt fragt
was ist denn agad ihnen das ist pflanzt
dieses stilmittel und wenn mich schon
länger verfolgt der weiß ich benutze das
total gerne und ihr könnt auch
stattdessen sauerkirschen actors auch
erdbeersaft oder bananen nektar alles
was ihr möchtet ihr könnt alles
verwenden dann flüssigkeiten und das
gebe ich jetzt einfach in meinem kopf
habe denn er hat noch nicht an und
verrät das zusammen mit der akademie
[Musik]
das ruft jetzt zusammen mit der agile
zwei minuten lang sprudelnd kochen denn
dann kann die agile binden und
trainieren und unser groß ist eigentlich
jetzt schon fertig das ganze gehe ich
jetzt noch kurz an die seite dann würde
ich das nicht so ganz heiß später auf
meine torte geben muss so 15 bis 20
minuten sollte das ganze schon ein wenig
ausführen aber wir haben wir noch eine
sache zu tun nämlich unsere erdbeeren
zurechtschneiden das mache ich jetzt
nebenbei
[Musik]
im vorletzten schritt werden jetzt
einfach nur die halbierten bzw
geviertelten erdbeeren auf die krim
gelegt und danach gehen wir den guss
drauf jetzt könnt ihr schauen möchte er
das anordnen schönen akkurat gerade oder
einfach durcheinander ist vollkommen
egal ich mache das auch mal so wie ich
lust habt heute nach einer schönen
akkurat gerade
[Musik]
die gesamte oberfläche ist jetzt voll
mit leckeren frischen erdbeeren und
meine aktive mit dem satz ist jetzt auch
einigermaßen abgekühlt also nur noch
handwarm und jetzt nehme ich mir ein
loch und gibt es dann ganz vorsichtig
löffelweise drüber
einmal wartezeit haben wir jetzt noch
aber die 20 bis 30 minuten können uns
bestimmt gedulden denn in der zeit muss
der bus schön fest werden und dann
können wir den tortenring entfernt und
unsere erdbeer standorte endlich
genießen
[Musik]
b
meine lieben ich bin mir sicher dass ihr
jetzt auch richtig lust habt auf die
leckere torte hier unten in der infobox
schreibe ich euch wie immer die genauen
mengenangaben macht einen screenshot
geht schnell einkaufen und dann ran an
den ofen und dran an den schneebesen ran
an den speck vernünftig wünsche euch
ganz ganz ganz viel spaß und nachmachen
und ich freue mich wie immer über eure
fotos mit dem hashtag ins kittchen auf
facebook stirb langsam aus wir wissen es
alle aber instagram und facebook da bin
ich mich sehr darüber freuen und dann
freue ich mich natürlich auch wenn ihr
meinen kann kostenlos abonniert dann
verpasst du natürlich auch nichts mehr
und dann sehen wir uns auch im nächsten
mal auf dieses kitchen schützen
[Musik]